Speaker 1: This is super interesting. Yesterday,
the Ukrainian President, Volodymyr Zelensky,
spoke to the U.S. House and the U.S. Senate, and,
as I said earlier, made a number of requests for
equipment. And we've already talked about how
Joe Biden is sending some additional equipment
to Ukraine. But at least for the time being,
not getting involved in creating or enforcing
a no fly zone. And one of the fascinating things
to see has been the right wing media tear itself
apart about how they're supposed to react to
this. And it's there's sort of two sides to this.
And both want to criticize Joe Biden, just
understand that they all want to slam Biden,
but they're at odds as to why it's sort of like
the flat-Earthers where we've said before all
of the flat-Earthers agree the earth is
flat, but often the defense is they give
conflict with each other. So one story that some
in the right wing media are telling is Biden's bad
because he's not giving Zelensky what he
wants. Zelensky's asking for all this stuff.
We should be sending it to Zelensky. Biden's not
giving Zelensky everything he wants. Joe Biden
is a disaster for for that reason. OK, another
story from other members in the right wing media
is Russia and Putin really aren't that bad.
Ukraine's bad, and we really shouldn't be
helping them. Very much so Biden's bad because
he has sent military assistance to Ukraine.
That's a conflict. They both say Biden's bad. One
says Biden's bad for not giving Ukraine enough
stuff. The other says Biden's bad for giving
stuff to Ukraine. And it was made front and center
last night on Fox News. Sean Hannity invoked
Ronald Reagan in his monologue to support
sending more to Ukraine than what Biden has sent.
Laura Ingraham invoked Reagan in her monologue
to say We should not be sending stuff to
Ukraine. It's fascinating. Look at this.
Take a look at this clip from last night.
Speaker 2: Bad actors, we should learn the
lessons from Reagan if Zelensky what he's asking
for, the weapons that they need so they can
battle back against Russia, the Ukrainian people.
Speaker 6: Reagan won the Cold War by rebuilding
our economy and growing our military, which
took a few years after the devastation we
faced under Carter. The same pattern will have
to play out here. Now, as the angle is said,
from the beginning, the situation in Ukraine is
a horrific tragedy. It breaks all of our hearts,
but we have to be prudent and we have to be
thoughtful in our response. And right now,
the US is simply in no good position to engage in
another protracted military struggle. We need time
to repair our economy, reform our military and get
political leadership that actually works. Is good,
is smart. Whatever happens, we cannot
repeat the same mistakes we made after nine.
Speaker 1: So that's just fascinating. Hannity
says the lesson from Reagan is we've got to arm
them. And Laura Ingram says the lesson from Reagan
is we shouldn't arm them. And of course, it all
is in service of their overarching narrative,
which is Biden's bad. They agree Biden's bad
but for different reasons, and Laura Ingram spent
most of last night pushing back on on sending
equipment to Ukraine. And of course, it's a
legitimate position to take that we shouldn't send
stuff to Ukraine. Reasonable people can disagree
about that perfectly fine conversation to have.
For them, it's all in service to attacking
Biden. Here's Laura Ingraham pushing back
on the fighter jets debate to attack Joe Biden
Speaker 2: to be where President Zelensky urged
him to be today, which is leading the world in
helping Ukraine fight for their own freedom.
Speaker 6: Joe Biden can't lead the United States
Senator Cotton with all due respect. I mean,
when I hear when I hear President Joe Biden being
told you need to lead the world, first of all,
you know, with all due respect to President,
Zelensky is obviously incredibly heroic.
You know, he's fighting for his country as he
should. But we have a president who is, as I said,
in the angle, essentially a hologram. He is not
an active president defending our interests here,
let alone the president of the world. So I mean,
I think going down that road is kind of ridiculous
at this point.
Speaker 1: So there's
Laura Ingram and one more Laura
Ingram clip here, she says,
isn't all of this that we're sending to
Ukraine just going to give them false
hope and they're just going to lose anyway?
Speaker 2: So in many cases, I mean, just look,
today, they announced a transfer of $800 million
of weapons to Ukraine, as welcome should have
been done a month ago or two months ago, and it's
still just a fraction of what Congress proposed
last week. Look, the Ukrainian people and army
have proven that they are capable of fighting
the Russians. We need to encourage them to do
so, and we need to provide, you know, weapons
that they need to fight the Russians.
Speaker 6: Now you don't think you don't
think we're giving the Ukrainians at this point
and the rest of the world false hope. If you think
that you think, given the fact that Russia
is closing in on Ukraine at this moment,
you heard the air raid sirens outside of Lviv.
Speaker 1: OK, so you get it isn't. Aren't we
just giving them false hope by giving them
stuff? And then lastly, here's Laura Ingram
reacting to Mitt Romney, saying Send them
what they are asking for. People are dying
Speaker 2: sent of the planes that they
need. They want MiGs. Get them the MiGs.
Speaker 6: Why don't you pay for them
now? Did he ever stop to think that
more people could die if we send Ukraine MiGs?
Speaker 1: So there is, well, it's actually going
to be worse if we send stuff now again. There is
a legitimate conversation about to what degree
should the United States be involved here, either
individually or as part of NATO's? That is a fair
debate. But it is fascinating to see. Number
one objective is Biden, but that's the primary
goal here, some right wingers justifying it
in one way, other right wingers justifying
it in a way that directly conflicts. But Biden
definitely is bad that they're very sure of.